so uh firstly i've got apologies
from councillor stuart any other
apologies
okay so apology from council stuart then
to record one for councillor brian the
meeting's still going at 3 30. ish
okay council ballot will move segment
council meetings
any discussion all of over i contrary to
clear and caring
any conflicts of interest for recording
you're a council appointee on tktt
you'd like to you'd like to declare to
record
uh well um
i think given the potential nature of
the business
and and you might consider that nearer
the time i think
you have to act in the best interests of
the entities that's in front of you
at the time and if you do have that
conflict sitting there because of a
transaction or
events that might occur then you know
that warrants due consideration
okay so you don't wish to record the
conflict
okay
tonight um no so it's not coming now
all right just before i come to
acknowledgements
uh sorry i'll come to acknowledgements
first um
i'd like to just record the
superintendent john price the district
commander
of police received an onzym so that's a
new zealand order of merit
services to the police and the community
and whilst john isn't
a resident in the district we certainly
have a lot to do with him with various
forums we're at
his brother is um may not know he's a
principal of swan another school
so and i believe he was a teacher before
he went into the police so
from what i understand it's a thoroughly
nice journalism engagements we have with
him and
there was quite a ride up there
including working with
post the mosque shootings as well
something a lot to do with so
thoroughly deserving of that recognition
uh the noise
also like to recognise that tika tuatara
trust
celebrated the 10th anniversary and held
an open day on sunday so
it's really great to see the progress
the trust made in these last 10 years
i think personally they've made very
real progress since they've had greg
burns on board they've been a lot of
work
before that so i know councillor
atkinson
has been he'd been a long-term trustee
and now uh councillor blackie so thank
you both for
the contribution your contribution has
helped shape those last
10 years i also just like to record
very sadly the passing of their
shoemaker
gears with a former oxford ear county
councillor oxford here board councillor
2001 to 2004. he's also
a staff member of the council in the 90s
and his wife was
presently on staff that was really sad
and his funeral
service was held yesterday so i just
like us to stand and
at the moment silence for this
thank you
okay so
we come now to item 4 which is the
members
register of interests
step 3 so that's just updated that
record adrian is not really if
members any members have any are we
noting this
receiving this is this going to be a
regular item
okay okay
so it's just um for noting no action
required
if any member has any changes they'd
like just communicate that directly to
sarah rather than
here at the meeting but that's what's
recorded there okay
so we come to confirmation of minutes
first for 5.1
pages 14 to 18 it's a recommendation
these are the notes of the meeting held
on the 21st of december
so i prepared today moved to council
williams secretary councillor duty
okay no you weren't either council
redmond
any discussion all those in favor aye
contrary to clear that carried i'll come
to 5.2 and 5.3
when we're in public excluded later
there any matters arising anyone wishes
to make
that took amaze okay so
we now come to deputations and
presentations
first is item 6.1 buckpiece road
residence traffic concerns
i'd like to invite marion rouse marianne
mouse please
uh to come forward
thank you miriam so miriam's going to
write and speak about residents concerns
with traffic on buckley's road
um so we've already mastered the system
there that's excellent so the button
so you've got the button pressed you're
good to go
so up to 10 minutes including questions
i'll give a bit of leeway there um but
um it's
an indicative time for people so we look
forward to hearing from you and
now members tab five item 6.1 has
background material
that was received in advance thank you
thank you very much
mr mayor councillors ladies and
gentlemen
the mirror has already introduced me i
am a resident of buckley's road
and the other petition organisers grant
and mark mcalpine wish to apologise for
not being present due to
prior engagements
we wish to formally present the district
council with the petition
of residents and ratepayers of buckley's
road which was taken during november
specifically regarding speeding traffic
volume of traffic
investigations into alleviating the
above
two issues and a period of time for the
investigation of these issues to be
carried out
as mr mia has said you already have
received
copies of the data i really can't stress
strongly enough
how the depth of feeling
and concern of residents
on buckley's road
it's a residential street and it is
multi-generational
there are a huge number of young
families in that area
multiple individual complaints have been
laid with
new zealand police and the district
council regarding the speed of vehicles
however due to their intermittent nature
no real action
has all progress has been gained
for the residents and rate payers
i'd now like to specifically talk to
some of the points in here so if
councillors have questions of me
i'm more than happy to try to answer
them
thank you the first
the first part of the data is
85 of houses
canvassed responded
to the petition so
50 signatures were achieved from 34
homes
there is one business directly on
buckley's road
and although they expressed concern
regarding the lack of street markings
for parking they did not participate in
the
in the petition all participants were
very thankful and genuinely pleased that
we were taking time to hear their issues
and collectively present this
information to council
buckley's road residents do not wish to
see their street being required to meet
a crash fatality
criteria and we would urge the mayor and
councillors to give duke and
consideration and work proactively
towards
a suitable resolution to the issues
some of the solutions or suggestions
that were put forward by residents were
speed bumps a batiste a pedestrian
crossing
chicanes to narrow the traffic flow and
potentially stop signs at either end of
buckley's road instead of just to give
way sign
to slow traffic down
84 were concerned about the volume of
traffic
there's a large number of truck and
trailer units now using
that street there are incomplete
road markings on buckley's road and some
of those
road markings have been obliterated due
to
recent road works down there
particularly outside of the fabric of
society shop
so therefore when you have vehicles
parked to go
customers to go in there they're not
actually using the car parking spacing
they're using the road and if you come
off coronation street
it becomes very tight
100 of all residents canvassed
were concerned about the speed of
vehicles
and primarily they are concerned about
children's safety
pedestrian safety the potential for
lowering the speed limit on the road
and the speeding occurs at all times
the estimation and we're not there to
to clock people and vehicles
but honestly this honor a number of
people commented on the fact that they
felt that the cars were doing between 80
and 100 kilometers an hour
again 100 of the people
who participated in
[Music]
the petition are adamant that there
should be an investigation into what's
going on down that street
again as we say there's been multi or
a number of of complaints brought
to the police or to
the district council regarding buckley's
road and
now because of the installation of the
traffic lights out on south brook road
buckley's road is now seen as a
cut-through street
and we believe that barclays road
is the largest i know that there's two
i know that there's collins street and
cone street
however collins street has got something
like seven or eight residential homes on
it
cone street is all fairly much
industrial buckley's roads residential
when you've got traffic flow
and speed
it becomes a pretty nasty combination
we also have two schools and two
day care centres in very close proximity
to
to buckley's road and families
use buckley's road as a pick-up drop-off
point
for their children to come through from
pearson lane
having come across the the main south
brook
road on the pedestrian crossings
so again we increase traffic
we increase children you get a speeding
car in there and
it's a recipe for disaster in our heads
we specifically asked for a period of
time in
the petition because we do not feel that
putting
a random police car down there in
buckley's road
is going to solve any of the problems
nor do we think that just putting a set
of
counter rubbers across the road
is going to solve it
we need to have a serious amount of time
looking at what is going on on that
street
again better road marking would be
another issue that should be
looked at
the queries i've come to council with
today which i have
logged with
[Music]
your god i'm governorate staff
your staff uh
what time frame does the council
envisage
undertaking an investigation into the
speed
and traffic volume on buckley's road
at a previous meeting with the mir and
the traffic manager
in late november it was alluded to that
a roundabout being built
or technically to be built in south
brock
and lights are to be installed at
coronation street intersection
which fundamentally would split traffic
and lessen the use of buckley's road as
a cut-through street
however what documented proof
do we have and because this is
an idea none of us can answer that
question
but i need to have something concrete to
take back to our residents
we've made a commitment to the residents
in buckley's road
to have something happen
should the point of the installation of
the roundabout and the installation of
lights at coronation street
be some months or potentially years away
what interim measures are the council
going to take
to alleviate these issues that are in
buckley's road
now
and specifically what is the intention
of council to do
to slow the vehicles down in the street
as i said it's my responsibility or it's
our collective responsibility that
mcalpine
finds myself to return to our fellow
residents
in buckley's road with something clear
and concise
for them to to get their heads around
we've it's just growing and growing and
growing
in buckley's road
so i thank you for your time and i look
forward to
seeing some progress in the very near
future on these issues
thanks thanks miriam to start start with
thank you for your thoughtful
presentation and i enjoyed receiving it
with the mccalpines recently can i just
say that i'm
not a roundabout proposed so i'm not
sure where that
came from but certainly lights are being
considered
uh as a safer crossing point for the
school so round the bounds is definitely
not that
i'm aware of um i don't recall saying
that
at the meeting but there's certainly
lights just just to clarify
lights are being considered uh and are
in this year's program
so yeah so within the next two years but
it's more to address the
a safe crossing point for the school so
just to let you know that
what i'm proposing to do today is after
questions from colleagues is to ask for
a report to come to council
with opt to investigate options which
would also include the report going to
the community regulation community board
because within their board area
and in terms of residence down there if
they'd like to know where
how we're going i'm very happy to attend
a meeting anytime with residents to
answer any questions they might have so
that's just at the up
at the outset what um some answers to
your points
we will come back to you around the
timetable that probably the earliest
reports probably march april somewhere
in that area if we were to
remember to answer all those points it
might take a bit of time to
assemble data of our own so we'll come
back to you with a timetable assuming
colleagues are in agreement with the
requests of a report
questions uh council duty followed by
council award
thank you very much for your report and
i'm just wondering
um things would would your um
group of residents along there be
prepared to look at
an interim type of safety measure you
know just a temporary
measure thing where to slow the traffic
down to see how effective it is first
before
spending quite a considerable amount of
money on actually
putting those in i'm sure that we would
be
willing to go through anything to slow
vehicles down
yes i watched one come through this
morning at half past six quarter to
seven
and man he was honking yeah so
i mean these things may um
be on part of someone's outside
someone's property that's the only thing
but they are only a temporary
temporary murder thing just to see how
it works so
um that's just something for the staff
to think about thank you
council award a lot of our council
thank you for your concerns um would a
slowing of speed and maybe jutter bars
two or three down the
length of the road would that would that
contain people from speeding's
and be helpful i think so i think
as as we've indicated with other
um ideas and suggestions
in the data sheet that you did receive
the majority of household holders would
take anything
just to slow traffic down just to slow
it down
uh council back hi
um yeah my question follows directly
from that um you
you you some of the residents have
suggested jata bars
do your people realize that you swapped
one problem for another
with judder bars the noise the vehicles
changing gear especially trucks and
trailers which are by far the worst
and then the vibration and the noise
when they hit them so just be careful
with
asking for jada bars you they you may
not like chatterbars one little bit
i understand your point
and and potentially there is that factor
however the cars won't be doing 80 to
100ks
and that really is the key point that
you know young families
are scared to let their children go down
to the mailbox
because of motorbikes or cars
or any other vehicles that are going
through
and the rate that they're going through
it
okay uh casabella
yes thank you very much for your
presentation totally take on board and
i've seen exactly what you're talking
about
um have you spoken at all to the
residents of coronation
street because obviously they're using
buckley's as a cut-through
they'll be coming through coronation as
well no we've stayed
specifically with residents of buckley's
road
and included in the responses
there are two properties whose garages
come out
onto buckley's road which is obviously a
direct impact to them
and that's coronation street corner uh
no they're there
and the other is on the corner at
highfield lane
right so do you think when we look at
that area we should look at it as an
overall as well as
the whole the whole situation
potentially yes thank you
thank you councillor redmond
uh thank you for your very comprehensive
submission
i think you presented your case really
well um
i guess they're both interrelated but
is your main concern the traffic volume
or the speed of vehicles
primarily it is speed
all streets are going to have traffic
we understand that
it's just that because of the lights
cars are using buckley's road coronation
street buckley's road or vice versa
probably not the other way around
because it's a gnarly little corner to
come out on coronation street
but they're using that to try and beat
the set of lights at south belt
that they get through the lights at pack
and save and then
they're diverting down buckley's road to
get
past the next set of lights
okay um carson medics
hi marianne and thank you again for your
great presentation i know it can be a
little bit nerve-wracking sitting up
there
um you mentioned heavy vehicles going
through there
how often is that a big problem not
specifically no
because we know that we have the flour
milk at the end of the
road or the stock sorry it's always in
my head it's the flour milk
the stock feed company at the end of the
road
and they're very good to be honest
they're very good but someone mentioned
it in the paperwork so therefore
we were it was our responsibility to to
put the concern down on paper
thank you now i was just wondering if if
it was a problem if there was a
um you know sometimes we'll get the
council mowers go through
i was just thinking in terms of whether
there would be any point in
limiting heavy traffic down down a
certain stretch of the road
because the um flower the
stock feed mill can actually come out on
coronation street from there
but um yeah mostly you just have some
other concerns so
thank you not as big a concern thank you
council records
any further questions well i think uh
miriam has indicated
my agreement with colleagues i think
we'll call for i'd like to call for a
report
which will come to our utilities and
writing committee and
we'll ask our staff and their writing
managers sitting at the back here to
look at all the options that have been
put forward including and especially the
ones you've put in the report
which is very in your presentation which
has been very comprehensive
to us today and um that'll come back to
both our
unr committee which utilities and
running or and or bring your hd
community board
and we'll keep in touch with you around
progress and time
as i said the offers are there if you
wish to have a meeting with residents
happy to come down there uh bring joanne
along with me if you'd like and we can
discuss more
um the concerns with residents and
around our process etc so
happy to do that if you if you'd like
that so just feel free to be in touch if
you'd like that to happen
thank you very much that report can we
also
include coronation street make sure
we're looking sorry i thought they were
taking it as a given it should be i
think it's council violence absolutely
right we talked about it in the
discussion we hear that there's more
broadly coronation as well it should be
included in that
absolutely all right is that anyone in
disagreement with that
okay so that's the course that we'll
follow thank you very much for your time
and appreciate all the work you've put
in to
coming to us today thank you thank you
very much ladies and gentlemen
you're welcome to save the rest of the
meeting if you'd like don't feel obliged
if you don't want to
[Laughter]
all right okay so um the first report
was to be 9.1 that's actually been
withdrawn
yeah the report on 9.1 we would
like to have a further reflection on
the options that we have there and i
think we would prefer
i think the view of our utilities and
roading team is
an option that retained ownership of the
um underlying land is preferable and
therefore
i think we'd like to just reconsider
what it is we are seeking there so um
your agreement would like to withdraw
that report today
thank you so anyone disagree okay so
we'll just withdraw that report we don't
need to resolve that
okay so we come now to um reports from
the community board chairs
uh or the community boards um i'm
advised that
um whilst requests went out to the
boards cheers if they wanted to present
they were quite comfortable with the
material that's there so um
first we have a report from the woodland
sifton community board
pages 32-35 um
there any board any board members of any
who on that board wish to make any
comment to that report
yeah sorry yes just have a question that
um
it's around the lake and i know council
blakely and i had a discussion on this
when we were talking about this paper
and
and um this paper
says that they're going to come to the
council over the lake
we don't own the lake and we don't
control the lake so therefore
i mean i just like that answered clearly
to the board
um and until such time we have very
little
say over cleaning up the lake and if i'm
to be brutally honest
i don't want to bar at that lake until
it is
dealt with so i'm
i'm not sure the sentiments as i read
the report is that we
will be the responsible people for
looking after and we're not
and i just want that okay clarified if i
can i think their points made
um in my my definite view is that it's
not our council response but
we're involved in the discussions about
trying to achieve quality but perhaps
kay
and she it might be helpful um did come
forward
thank you
good afternoon everyone um i think
the board is very well aware that the
council has
no ownership of this lake
at the moment um however they
are trying to be proactive and look into
the future
um that we do to have a workshop
on the lake and the issues of about the
lake um
late last year and um
they're aware that templeton and
ecan are working quite and our own staff
are working quite closely together to
try and
get all the issues on the lake but once
they've
been sorted and the lake eventually does
move towards
us the board is
quite keen to make the lake a
recreational has
assets for the district um in that
better management of the lake in
having
events rather than at the moment it's a
bit of
hodgepodge and it depends who gets there
first gets
gets the lag sort of thing so i think
that's what they're sort of aiming at
rather than
blaming the council as such i'm aware of
shaina's espera
and the board's aspirations there and
that's fine um
to raise which is totally the um
prerogative
and we are in partnership to try and get
it resolved even albeit that it's
not directly our council's
responsibility but we want to see a good
outcome
there so i think the point's fair i
think um
the way it was expressed there i can see
how counselor atkinson would
see that point um okay any other
questions there
you're prepared to move council redmond
seconded by
council atkinson did you wish to speak
to them thanks kay
uh just very briefly to um say this is
quite a comprehensive report
and i'm one of the council appointees on
the board along with councillor stuart
the board has been very proactive in
making submissions
um to various places and in fact the
council has
piggybacked off the back of some of the
board submissions
so while it may appear to be a small
board it certainly is proactive in a
number of issues so
i'm very pleased to uh move this
recommendation
so you can tell do you wish to speak i
just like to echo those comments of
counselor edmund uh in fact
board chair um shona puts a lot of work
into the submissions writes them herself
with some assistance from staff but she
certainly does
put a huge amount of time and so just
echo those remarks because
they are a high performing board and
we're lucky to have your contributions
so and the board's contribution
so any further speakers the reply
accounts redmond
put that all those in favor aye contrary
to clear that carriage
uh 9.3 cardboard to a huey community
board
any questions of that report
someone prepared to move
move uh councilman seconded
council atkinson do you wish to speak
council blocking
well again just to thank the board there
i mean chris greengrass just like china
is also
appears just about everywhere and
certainly puts in a huge amount of work
as does the rest of the board i might
add
and never a board that actually agrees
around the table if you have a look at
the votes
often there is either one or two
votes that go a different way which is
in my view a very healthy thing for a
year
for a board in a local community called
the local community to be doing so i
think it's
it works very well
we look forward to it afterwards trevor
um
echo those comments uh well said council
direct because it has a very high
performing board and we're lucky to have
in fact with all our boards um the
caliber we do and
the chairs providing the role that they
do so any further speakers
i'll put you which exercise rather reply
put that all those in favor all right
contrary to keep that carried 9.4 which
is
ops for the hoka community board pages
41-45
any questions of that report council
meetings
i just noted in here that there's no
mention in this report it's
i guess been an accidental omission but
there's no mention of this report about
the
um west ireland summer summerhill points
road water supply
amalgamation the consultations the work
that's been put into it
through the water advisory groups the
points road and the
joint up one with west ham summerhill
and points road
with those groups to reach an amenable
solution all of which have heavily
involved
the community board and there's no
mention of it and also there's no
mention in here of the
work that's gone in to mitigate issues
with
between the community and cls for the
composting facility that they want to
put in there
so i think those are two very important
omissions that need to be mentioned in
this report
very good point do you agree wendy we
could give that feedback
to staff to get the chair to consider
anything like hmm we're missing a few
big issues that we
we've dealt with in here yeah yeah okay
so with with any with those
additions which we've suggested would
you be prepared to move their
recommendation
yes with those editions and secreted by
councillor dirty
do you wish to speak to it council meals
i think i already did
[Laughter]
a second though yes i do um
this ward uh has gone through a few
little issues
um but the quite frankly the issues that
have come to this ward have been
horrendous and it's it's been a very
difficult
period for anybody to to deal with
things that uh were already quite out of
your control
so i really um commend the team very
much for the effort
and that they've put into this and
um and the other thing
is that um we at the moment uh we're
still going through
potential for a dog not park but a dog
recreation area
so we're just going through that part at
the moment changing them
well a dog there's a dollars and cents
between a dog park and a
dog recreation so yeah thank you
okay thank you any further speakers
um i'll put the recommendation all
that's in paper i
contrary to clear that carriage 9.5
pages 46 to 50 any questions
someone prepared to move council brian
secretary
the same it's a very well working board
if the issue seems to go through and
be dealt with quite efficiently any
other speakers
cats reckinson well just overall really
well for all the boards and we're at the
last one um
the level of reporting this year i think
is was outstanding i think along with
our staff working alongside the boards i
think it
clearly shows that the relationship
there is is very good because this is
very good information on all of them
through all of us i think they're
really good comments um and particularly
we should note that for a large period
this time was through covert
and it was a really difficult time for
our boards to meet and make submissions
so
and you see the level that have gone
through all there's been a significant
consultation achieved through that time
so
acknowledge the patience of the boards
and the chairs but also to acknowledge
our governance staff for all the work
that they've done to support
our boards through that time so
right from play should be exercised for
other player council brian
do you wish the exercise crop no okay
i'll put that
all those in favor please say aye
contrary to clear that carry
all right uh we're now up to item 9.6 so
that's pages 51-54 tab 11.
thank you and good afternoon all a short
report
is in reference to the proposed change
to the canterbury regional policy
statement
which relates to food as future urban
development areas
which are one of the products of the
ongoing collaborative process
and greater christchurch to identify
land for new urban development
for waimakuri those land areas uh
identified in
our space document which is a future
development strategy produced under the
recent nps for urban development
and those apply to rangura and takayapui
the change that ecan has put forward is
via streamline planning process
under the directions of the minister
which effectively truncates appeals and
that streamline planning process was put
forward because of the body of work that
has
preceded it in terms of hearings etc
that occurred
through sort of 2018-19 thereabouts
there is an opportunity here should you
wish to choose to do so
to make a submission on that
change of the regional policy statement
the submissions close on the 15th of
february
and i've couched that as being very much
one of providing information
and being supportive of the process so
far and that's really because
obviously there's a decision made at the
local level but then it goes through to
the minister
for final decisions around is this
meeting national direction does this
mean the rma et cetera
so that information may be beneficial
for those parties
along the way um particularly given that
there's no
scheduled hearing for this process um so
i've outlined a paragraph 3.6 those
matters that could be
included in a submission uh
it's on page 51 of your agenda i think
um which is around
how we're working on uh density reviews
particularly in context of the district
plan review
how we are working on structure plans
which is component
which in there is a component of density
but it's certainly an action dropping
out of our space
as in its own right certainly the
waimakariri housing needs report which
is a 70
odd page report that has been tabled to
you previously last year
by ian michelenko which identified a
number of
matters for uh council to follow up on
not only through rob hawthorne's
portfolio
but also through district planning
mainly aimed at densities and housing
typologies
and then lastly just around downstream
effects
of transport relating from the
development of these areas
and council's done some work in the
space in the last year or two
with its transport consultants so they
might be all matters that
council could choose to make available
to this process in the form of a
supportive information submission
and that may indeed be helpful with the
decision makers as they truck through
the process which i've outlined in
paragraph 4.2 so i'm
happy to put forward to recommend
recommendations a to c and take any
questions thanks true but before you do
um thank you for the speed in which you
put this report together or nearly there
would be a draft
submission but are we
quite we're quite aware of the speed in
which he can were
proposing this process so we had a quick
meeting last week and that's why the
reports here so
when it when it comes i'm happy to
circulate that draft
um to you all so you see that as well
but it's that's the reason why it's not
here in case you're wondering
and thanks trevor for pulling together a
really good report
um very quickly it is appreciated
councillor atkinson
um trevor can we can we circulate it to
all boards
all boards have an interest in the
scenario rather than just
um the the two that you've got listed
there
their opinion would be actually really
quite good in the future
and keeping them informed the second one
that i have is around downstream effects
why are we using still downstream
effects when traffic goes both ways
and we need to know the effects of that
in the future both ways so
why are we still using the terminology
downstream effects
speak that's because we've been used to
that in more recent processes and that's
the terminology being used
the submission need not refer to that
directly in any way so that would be
good
yes thank you uh
counselor followed by counselor dude
just a question on what you've said mr
mayor that
just wondering whether because email can
be done very very quickly
um whether we could perhaps change
potentially change b
to say um the counselor or the counselor
to review
the submission and the mayor to sign off
the final
or something along those lines rather
than right yep it's just i was a bit
worried about loading
timing-wise trevor i just thought that
it was difficult
what's the time frame for getting that
through
15th of february is the closing date
okay so
it's quite tight but i'm sure we can
achieve that absolutely
typical trooper oh yeah um
just thinking about dates
if we make it available it'll be
available for a limited time only
and those who have those who haven't
will have missed their opportunity
that's fine thank you i'm happy with
that a limited time only
yes yes second question sorry second
question
um can you just please explain to me
very quickly
what you mean by 3.6 when you say you've
endorsed a position
of achieving higher densities i
understand we're investigating it
but when you say endorsed a position of
high
achieving higher densities can you just
explain how
what your intentions are on that one
i think through our space we actually
did
sign up to achieving higher densities we
just haven't specified yet exactly
what what they will be so yeah it's a
commitment to achieve higher densities
correct um that's probably reasonably
generalized
two aspects to gyms they're certainly
out of their space process
we have endorsed through that process
moving from 10 households here to hectic
to 12
and that's yet to be implemented in
another process it's not this one
and then the second thing of course i
guess was reference to thinking about
the district plan review
and the new zoning provisions
okay
councilman duty
3.5 mainly on the same line about the
for higher density living and
environments
but um and really where is our
by the higher density whereas there are
larger sized
sections that people might want rather
than just
have a house with a fence around it so
we as our
showing of that that you know especially
in the community where is our thing of
having
various sized sections
yeah look really interesting question we
are under continual
sort of not pressure but
a way of thinking around providing
higher densities
mainly around affordability issues and
those types of things but there are
urban form issues
emissions issues transport issues and
those sorts of things and that's even
come out over the weekend with
the climate change commission sort of
thinking as well the general
approach still is around zoning
so provide different residential zones
within townships
we provide rural residential zones and
peri urban areas so two and a half
thousand square meters and then
as you know we've had some discussions
around rural zones as well
so back back to the residential zones
certainly there is still
a tool there to provide for a multi-unit
and there's a medium density then
there's a general density now
all of those have had lowered figures in
the district plan that we're putting
together now
but they are minimums so there's nothing
stopping
a developer still going far in excess of
that
it's just we're not requiring that
okay so uh that's that's where we sit at
the moment
and there's been instances in the past
where developers have
chosen to create larger lots than six
hundred
a quiet boy sovereign those guys are
often in the 700 category
and there's other examples around the
district as well
the other questions
okay so a recommendation while there was
a proposed recommendation by council
something like circulates a draft
submission
by email to councillors to review and to
then be signed off by the mayor
and to be lodged with environment
category okay
sorry circulate to draft submission
by email to counsellors to review
and to then be signed off by the mirror
and lodged with environment category
yes i'm sorry i was kidding i was just
not facing and then
yeah you've got the last bit
of your information before for
information
so just take out cardboard to a heavy
community board and ring your ashley but
and change it circulates this report to
all community boards
for information okay
so peer to peer move council by that
signal
of duty that's about that just speaking
to that realize that time is of the
essence and we've done a lot of work in
the space so
i'm pretty sure that the submission will
just we'll be able to endorse
our position on that and i'm totally
happy for the me to sign off the final
changes
uh council duty thank you yes it's
important that our position is well and
truly
uh met with with our recommendation
thank you
thank you further speakers council at
my questioning around downstream effects
being part of that 2050 and
spending a few weeks doing that and
banging the table about downstream
effects to find it
in our own submission would actually be
quite upsetting considering that we
actually did get the downstream effects
removed from the 2050 plan because
we have to acknowledge that we are
becoming bigger and so is selwyn
and traffic is two-way and otherwise all
we will do
is start looking at traffic flows into
christchurch and what comes out
gets very little attention and and it's
as important
as the inward traffic so down downstream
effects
does not mean both ways it actually
means to flow into
christchurch so that's the reason for my
questioning around that i think it's
extremely important
okay further speakers rather reply
council bonus
okay i've got the recommendation all
those in favor please say i
contrary to clear that carrot thanks
trevor
we'll see you at the good drop after
[Laughter]
okay we now have uh mentors referred
from committees and community boards
um 10.1 so
oh sorry you'd like to declare a
conflict cancer bro
sorry i did say cancer bro
no oh did i i'm sorry i thought i said
counselor brian
pardon oh me
sorry yeah same ward same diff
apologies won the beast
all right so um to 10.1 pages 55
to 86 tab 12. um so
we've got ellie with us as well you've
been to our table before ellie
you have okay oh it's good to see you
joanne thank you
thank you um see this report
recommending speed limit changes
and south kaiapoi has been referred for
decision from
ohoka oxford and kaipoi to ahiri
community boards
the report itself is seeking approval to
implement a 60 kilometer an hour speed
limit on the length of main north road
neves road rights road and double days
road
the changes are proposed to support the
activities and then around the area
and also the introduction of the shared
user path on main north road
the changes have been assessed using
waka kotahi's speed management guide
which sets out the framework for
assessment
as required in the land transport rule
just in terms of feedback i would note
that
on speed limits the feedback was quite
split
and you can see that by attachment one
um in particular section of main north
road from neebs road
north to the chi point urban limit where
um
i guess the feedback was um
sorry the percentage of people who
agreed to that was around 43 percent
um
i guess one thing to be aware of is
police and nzta
have provided also provided feedback and
they
have both supported the change to the 60
kilometer in our speed limit
um and in particular the police noting
the
crash history around that area as a
reason to
reduce it to 60 kilometers an hour
i would also note that at the time of
consultation naita who did not support
the changes because council had not
prioritised speed through to ahi village
at the council meeting on the 1st of
december council approved the 40
kilometer an hour speed limit through
tulhiwi and the implementation of that
will be carried out in conjunction with
the shovel ready
projects um we haven't sought
formal feedback from my naitah at this
stage
on um the uh
i guess feedback now following the
approval of
that 40 kilometer an hour speed limit
approval but what we are suggesting is
that
the wording under recommendation e
is updated to reflect that and to note
that the speed limit
change has since been approved and that
we all
seek a further response from nzta
ah sorry not easy to run um just the
other thing i will also note is
under table 1 in the recommendation
neebs road this was
raised at the kuiper community board
should not say the entire length my
apologies
that should read east of the
christchurch northern motorway
um happy to take
not at this point for us colleagues for
questions
yeah can i can i just suggest that i
don't even know why we need e
if why is e needed in there specifically
why don't we just remove it all together
i think it was added at the time because
we were aware of that feedback and we
hadn't
finished working through the tewahee
speed limit
um if council consideration is they
would like that
recommendation removed then they'd be up
to colleagues but
my suggestion is i don't think it's
needed so we can debate that
when it comes to to the table i'm sure
there's a recommendation recommendations
discussed
so any questions thank you councillor
edmund councillor barnett
thank you joanne on page 61
the assist in safe operating
speed from helles to the
kaiapoi urban boundary is 80 kilometers
per hour
the proposed speed limit is 60.
are you proposing any
treatment on that stretch of road to
make it apparent
that it is not a rural road
otherwise i can see where councillor
brian may have this conflict of interest
yeah and look that's a really good
question so
yes what we're doing as part of that
work
as the lanes through there are very wide
so we are actually narrowing them up
um somewhat to try and help rein
reinforce that 60 kilometer in our speed
limit
it was a discussion we had with nzta
staff
when we went through the process of
originally
talking about the speed limits and
whether we could get the 60 there
and that was something that they were in
favour of
the other thing i think just to be aware
of
is there has been a consent granted
for um i guess development of
the wake home builders site
which was the old bull farm site
on the western side of the road just
south of cairport and that's
likely to include some work to
develop that site for the building
business so
we're going to be seeing i guess that
creep
further south as well with
the 80 kilometer in our speed limit one
of the options we looked at
was whether we could fit a section of 80
in there
but in terms of the meeting the land
transport rules
for the minimum length it was too
short so we weren't able to to get that
in there for an 80 kilometer an hour
and the other thing that i think feeds
into that is
the feedback we get from people is they
don't like speed limits that
change up and down along the road
there's a preference for consistency
so that's what we've tried to get here
so yes we will
be doing some physical works and we will
need to monitor
and that will include some traffic
counts six months after
implementation to make sure we're
achieving what we said we would
and if we don't then we would need to
look at some
further measures and it could be things
like a flush median
or some something else to create that
sense of narrowing
because
just first of all obviously this report
went to the two community boards have
you got the feedback from
this particularly oxford ohio i'm quite
interested in their feedback
from memory i think oh
scratching of my um brain now to be
honest i don't have these specific
comments
but did they have any concerns i'm
particularly talking about the tramway
yeah i think the comments from nikki
correct me if i'm wrong
but there were some comments around how
far the 80
came up the tram wrote i think there was
a reasonable level of comfort with what
was proposed
there's obviously the concerns about
safety on the off ramp as it merges
with trend mode and i think we're
trying to reinforce that slower speed
limit there will have some safety
yeah just around the corner to that
eye okay
any further yeah cool and the second
question i had was i was interested in
the comment from christchurch city
council about consistency of speed
limits down marshland's road
um i can you just explain to me what
is the current situation with speed
limits down marshmallows road that
you're aware of
marshlands road all of it is now 16
kilometers an hour
um i know there has been some
unhappiness with that in different
sections
probably particularly through the rural
part um i think
for us the
old waimakaru river bridge is very
constrained it's very narrow
having this 60 kilometer an hour there
from a safety perspective would be
really important
i think there's a lot going on in
kayanga with the businesses
and and retail the pub
and everything that's happening around
there so i can see
um certainly there's really good
justification for the 60
through kainga across the bridge and
through to
at least hella's entrance because that
you know there's a lot going on there's
traffic signals there now
there's steve perry and all the
industrial
businesses have been happening around
there so
so you know as well as i do that people
won't change on
a speed limit necessarily they'll change
their behavior on
what the road looks like and the power
road feels the environment
what budget have we got in place to
actually
correspond every time we change a speed
limit like this where do we have a
budget in place
to make changes to the road environment
along that whole stretch
of all of these roads that is our
responsibility
um to actually endorse that this would
be a 60.
um yes and we do that in part through
some of our project budgets so the likes
of the cycleway budget has
we've included in there doing some work
to narrow up the lanes
the speed limit signs to make sure that
that's reinforced
through our minor safety budget we have
do have some budget for
repeater signs and bits and pieces
um and i think that that
we would be likely to be get really good
compliance
from the old winemaker river bridge
through turn
north of knees right if we're going to
have an
area that is a slight challenge it would
be kaiapoy
um through 10 knees roach so that short
section
but i think because it's such a short
if we needed to do some additional road
marking or something like that we would
be able to manage that through our
maintenance budgets
further questions some of you have
council right concern as
except they yeah see
well he's on that sorry he's on sorry
it's
it's on the summary so it's the summary
agenda at the front so
okay and some of pet's second uh second
accounts the meetings
uh counseling concert thank you mr mayor
look i think you all
know my uh views on the speed limits and
we've got to be very careful about
where we're doing things and where we're
not um
the question that council redmond raises
around the environment
uh being rural i think that's actually
well gone
we're putting a park and ride in
achilles timber
there's a service station right there
right next door to that there's a
trellis work place right next door to
that is steve murphy's if you
and then you're on a set of lights then
next door to that you go down the road
there's uh
there's about four houses and then there
is clements drilling and then you've got
about 20 metres in your house driveway
and then from there on you've got a
business which is the uh
the grass growing uh
exercise along with wag horn builders
and then on the opposite side of the
road you have winter's farm who are
there taking in and out their equipment
at odd times and and trying to get in
and out of their driveway so
i think the environment itself is
actually something that requires
um taking it down i mean i must admit
that i was in a um
in a jeep cherokee the other day that
does 100 kilometers and 200 kilometers
an hour and 2.6 seconds
um very few of those around and i don't
think from the lights to the old wimac
bridge that many of them would take up
that challenge of 2.6 seconds so
um it's a very short um it's a very
short piece that we're talking about and
to be quite honest believe that
at a different speed limit to uh to get
to the bridge would in my view just be
ridiculous
um and the other thing is you all know
my feelings on that diabolical
uh uh connection of a
cycleway that should have been in a
different place you're 400 millimeters
off that road
and 60 kilometers an hour 400
millimeters in place
from a tower seal from a from a piece of
steel hurtling down the road
and driving off through 400 mils gap
onto a walkway is not desirable so if
it's at 80 k's you can imagine the mess
that can happen
and it can happen at 60 k's an hour so
i think that the road environment is
ready for this change
i mean you know christ yourself we all
know i think about the petition that's
sitting out there with mr ducey and
and grant harris about the speed limits
on martians road and i think they have a
very valid point on martian's road but
certainly from chinese corner back to
coyote where there's
um there's uh the reason
i think to to drop this back and i think
the environment
certainly on one side of the road
definitely
um will dictate that and the more
cyclists so that do come down there the
more visual that will be
but i mean we've we've put the cycle way
there as i say it's 400 millimeters
between that and the main carriageway
you have uh hellas which people are
turning left and right out of there is a
bus stop right outside there there was
traffic
lights there are trucks coming and going
and there's a pretty busy piece of
piece of turf through there and then
even once you take
the traffic and put them on the motorway
into the into the new motorway i might
add
it will still be a pretty heavily used
piece of road so
um i think that it's absolutely
necessary in this particular case
because we have the proof in front of us
that we need to drop the speed limit to
something sensible
and i think 60k is sensible in this
particular
area as it stands well i'll say when the
cycleway
officially happens if you like
council meetings okay do
sorry council redmond
thank you mr mayor i'd just like to
comment on councillor
atkinson's um inference regarding my
question
i was referring from helles to kaiapoi
urban
as being rural certainly the other area
is not rural
and the area from helles to kaiapoi
irvine in my view
as joanne has confirmed does need some
treatment to make it look different
to what i would describe loosely as a
rural
area so
i'm happy that that treatment is going
to occur
i would hope some treatment could occur
when the actual um speed limit does take
effect
because i think otherwise motorists will
lightly cruise along there at maybe 70
or 80 k's
as the data seems to indicate so
i'm not unhappy that it is reduced to 60
but i think we need to give motorists a
bit of the heads up
caswells yeah
i'm finding it quite um hard to accept
all these
reductions and speeds around the areas
our cars are getting more modern
capable and crashing and more safely
when they do
unfortunately christmas period
four times more deaths on our road
with all these speeds being reduced all
around new zealand so
it doesn't seem to be solving the
problem of their
excellent rates around new zealand we
it's probably we should be more looking
at driver education as far as i'm
concerned
rather than just dropping the um
the speeds down the road between helles
and carpool
is definitely not a 60k
area so we've got to do some major
reinforcing there
um to make it look like it's a 60kz
area otherwise the government's going to
get some good revenue
if you get a policeman sitting down
there road and that's not the only road
we've got lots of road
in their area we had a presentation
before about
speeds on road um it's actually more
education
and um rather than the speed because
we mentioned buckley's road just before
um
he's got a 50k zone on the the residents
are moaning because they're probably
doing 85 down there
so sometimes it's not actually a speed
that's going to
speed limit's going to solve it so it's
happening all over new zealand but
i'm very reluctant to support something
there that's not
statistically getting followed up by
rates
around the whole of new zealand coming
down because of doing this top thing and
we're getting a lot of flack by lowering
some of the speeds around the areas that
don't look like they're meant to be
well they shouldn't be reduced
councilman barnes would hit it right
this time
yes it's interesting because initially i
was going to vote against this
when i first looked at the report and
that's why i had quite a few questions
and i was particularly interested in
hearing from the two community boards
and hearing that they have supported it
knowing that these areas are the quite
small stretches of road really
in in the scheme of things um and so to
do 60 along them is not a significant
um problem for a driver it doesn't take
them that much longer to travel those
roads
but my big concern is budget because i
feel like we're getting a national
direction
to reduce speed limits but the only way
of
successfully making people travel that
speed is to improve the road condition
and to put in road calming measures of
some sort
and yet we're getting no additional
budget from wakata kotahi
so those things to me just don't compute
so
tram road annoys me because the problem
with the tram road off ramp is an easy
ta
makata kotahi problem it's actually not
a local
council problem it's the fact that it's
a poorly designed
intersection with a very small runoff
and a very small
emerging lane and that is actually
something that needed to be sold
by the people who own the motorway which
is nzta
so i'm a bit annoyed that you know the
vet will put in a 60 and then we have to
look at our little tiny bit of that
that's actually owned by us
and say how do we make that into a 60
when it's a rural road um when it should
actually be that they should be looking
after the the actual problem residents
are worried about
is getting on and off the motorway so
that one and that one worried me but but
counselor mailings
reassured me the feedback from the board
has said it's only a short distance
and i have no problem with people
reducing the speed but it still doesn't
show
the problem of people merging on top of
each other so i don't want that problem
to be overlooked it will help but it
won't
solve it the other problem we've got is
consistency around the district
if you look at the main north road from
um
colors through to kaiapoi and then you
look at woody rangiora road which is 80.
i mean that's not consistent woody
rangira road has
lots and lots of entrances and lots of
activity and a major major
five crossroads intersection in the
middle
it's narrow it has a cycle lane on one
side
and it's 80. so you know we need to make
sure that we're not just
doing bits of roads around the district
and throwing budget at it
when there are other roads that also may
actually need it more
than that batch of road so i had some
concerns with that
um river road your favorite
river road i i go down there and i
struggle to keep to the 50k speed limit
because of the way it looks
we have not done any road treatment on
the rural side of that road
to make it look like a 50k road we
haven't had any money to do it
um and yet we've put it at a 50k so
my concern about this this piecemeal
change of speed limits
is the fact that we're not consistent
and that we're not getting any more
budget to improve the road from
nzta i will support this because of the
support from the boards
and because of the arguments i've heard
but i think
anyone who gets ticketed from client boy
to hellas
because they're not doing 60 i actually
feel quite sorry
um i'm going to speak now and then
followed by council blackie just to say
that
good comments have been made by
colleagues i actually agree with
councilman i think coming into this i
was a bit too minded myself
around it and it was the process that
had been gone through with
the prospective boards uh to get to this
point
um that sort of swung my support in
in terms of vote council rankings is
right
and we've got to have a a consistency of
speed
and it's no point and because on one
hand we were telling nzta they did last
year
through the end they got it all wrong
and they should have followed our
community board's recommendation around
that so on the other hand if we then
start
having different speeds it would have
made us look a bit hypocritical really
in the respect of where we were coming
from so i do think it's really important
that we do have a consistent speed
and that consistency of speed is uh one
that
suits the environment and having a
footpath coming along that part of
kaiapoi now
um swings me in the sense that you've
you need to have it so it's a safe
environment for people to be coming down
the points around the off ramp
and tram road are really good points by
council demand we had a meeting with
nzta last year following a crash on that
bridge and we
are still waiting for a response there
but part
part of that was to consider lights for
lights at that
corner and safety measures so they are
still seeing what they can do there and
we're keeping
uh pressure on nzta in that respect to
honour that
commitment that they gave at that
meeting but one of the tools that they
asked
us to consider was to reduce speed in
that area because that will help them
in terms of issues on that bridge and
people coming onto there but
it's one part of that measure the other
was lights and other treatments you see
you're right to raise it council obama
but we were
part of a broader conversation there
with
nzta staff and a particular individual
whose name escapes me at the moment that
petitioned us fairly hard on
on on that and rightly so because her
daughter was involved in a
pretty serious question my sister my own
sister
many years ago also was involved in a
very similar crash and it was
pretty devastating for her at the time
so i do recall
that issue plus the other one so i the
two healing measure i'm pleased that
we're not including that in there
because we have
the meters past we have been through the
consultation exercise there
and we have reduced the speed and last
week we included in our
long-term plan uh resource budget
to achieve a footpath era so and the
feedback i've had from
the aunties and the rooney when i saw
some of them at the weekend they're very
happy with
that inclusion so i don't think there
would be the same reservation there that
there
perhaps might have once been so look um
the
uh that's all i've got to say i'm going
to support the other thing is i
do have sympathy for the petition that's
currently out we have with respect to
martian road it does not seem right if
it's 60 all the way along there
and i wish those who are organizing that
petition all the best
hopefully they can achieve some common
sense along there it's a very long
stretch and they have a 60
doesn't seem to me to be right but
that's
another process for another council but
for what it's worth i do support the
direction that that's going
right uh council becky
i'll be brief because most of my points
have been covered the big two of course
consistency and safety um i agree
entirely
with the minimum separation between the
road and the
and the water cycle way you've got to
have 60 there you can't have 80.
the consistency thing again is very
important if you're chopping and
changing
um it's it's a nightmare um and the only
other thing i wanted to say was
councillor stewart was it he or might
have been the community board made the
point about that very ugly
um fencing over the kaikanui issue
i've had a look at that and i totally
disagree it's a re it's about a 1.5
meter high
height in cyclone barrier which you have
to have because they can fall into a
creek
so i just make the point i've got no
problems with the aesthetics of the
of what you put there um
do you wish to exercise say your
sickening spinach
[Music]
oh look when it comes to this i i kind
of
cringed a little bit at first too
because i'm a driver who likes to get up
to the speed limit as quickly as
possible and travel at it
um so whenever we start talking about
lowering speed limits you know i like
probably most people cringe a little bit
but with regards to these you know it
has been consulted
it has been really quite consulted upon
it's been really quite um
six and one half dozen of the other in a
lot of these cases but
just like the points that that most of
my colleagues here have made
um we need with regards to the main
north road
um you know we we do need some
consistency along there
i mean we've had when you drive down
marshland's road into town until just
recently
the speed limit changes about oh
probably seven or eight times
you know it's hard to know and of course
there are still speed cameras parked up
on the side of the road and you really
have no idea
what you're supposed to be doing half
the time so actually having a bit of
consistency
especially given the changes that we've
got particularly on our side of the
bridge
you know with with our park and ride
facilities and the very very
popular cycle route
everybody that that's been anywhere is
near there recently has seen
just a massive volume of cycles cyclists
coming through and using that so
i think we do need to to keep those guys
safe as well
with regards to tram road again that is
a safety thing it's you know
we've had i've had constituents approach
me about it um with
with some um major safety concerns about
that stretch of road
and the part of tram road that we want
to lower to to 60 is only a very
short stretch and it really does just
take in
the the most dangerous part of it and
allow
us a little bit more leeway to to
implement more safety measures i guess
and until something a little bit more
permanent
is done but it if nothing else you know
because that merged lane onto tram road
is too short
you know if you're doing 100 it just
it's not a merge lane it's a
slow down and hope you don't get taken
out lane so
uh you know before you hit the lamp post
so
so i don't really have a problem with
that either and and um
looking at the current mean operating
speeds
that that um on page 61 that we have
here
double days road for instance we're
talking about dropping the entire road
length from 100 to 60 which sounds
pretty extreme but
if you look at the current mean
operating speed it's 45 to 49 kilometers
so you know nobody's even going to get
up to the 60 anyhow so it's not
you know it looks like people are losing
a lot but they're not
and and by and large the other mean
operating speeds are um
within reasonable parameters as well so
whilst it sounds pretty extreme to drop
all these limits to 60. they are
consistent with the government's road to
xero program
and i don't think they're actually as
extreme as they look on paper so i'm
happy to support this anything that
keeps our people
safer than great and i'll just have to
remember like many others to
not have such a heavy foot whenever i
drive through some of those areas
thank you um any further speakers
got straight considering
this is something that people hold
pretty dear to their heart they like to
drive their cows and
i think uh council mailings is right and
a lot of us in fact i wish
more people on the motorway would get to
get to the speed a hell of a lot quicker
so you merge properly
um however look uh
you know some of the concerns around uh
spending extra dollars between
the exit of kaiapoi to hellas corner i
think uh
reasonably invalid um there are
businesses along there and yes they may
be
uh look as other rural businesses but
there is now a two metre path
there with as i say a 400 millimeter gap
between that and the road it is very
obviously changed
there is curb down there concrete curb
which gives you a separation
um from that road it is council meetings
just hit the nail on the head
every day you go down there there is
cyclists on that cycleway
the environment is hugely different once
all those cones and things have gone
to what it was yesterday when it was
winter's paddock
and no one was coming and going from a
business which is now waghorns
and no one was coming and going from the
places at the at the grass
place we've always forget what that's
called
glenn scott's place there we are um
easy anyway um coming and going from
there so there's a
hugely different environment to what it
was
12 months ago and and i wouldn't like to
see us actually spend mega dollars on
there i want to see a test
that people are sticking to 60 60ks
because what we're talking about here a
lot of the time is peak times
particularly sundays and sundays where
people are on the cycleways and people
may not be commuting but they're
actually looking at paddocks if you like
to see if there's sheep or cattle in
them
i think i think it's extremely important
that we do take note of what
has changed now and i'll be really
interested to see what the
the natural behavior of people is down
there i think it is very different
to ring your wooden road i
have absolute sympathy that we need the
cons consistency
but you're talking about 220 meters as
opposed to 2.2 kilometers
those figures won't be right but you get
my meaning it's 10 times the distance
down ranging of wooden road than it is
between
the exit of kaiapoi and the uh and
heller's meets again on there
the things that uh councillor blackie
talks about
the new cyclone fence that there that's
the the new wooden fence that's going to
go right down the side of
where the drain is that uh that exists
there now they are all
very different features in that
stretcher road than have ever been there
before
now i still think the cycle lays in the
wrong place
it is there it needs to operate and we
need to make sure
that people are using that safely the
other end for me
from there on from hell is on there's
just no question
it's full of businesses i mean i forget
my children when they were young
used to try and count steve murphy's
trucks while they were there and they
could never get around the corner
by the time you got around the corner on
the motorway they'd lost count and could
never count them all
so that tells you how many trucks are in
that yard and how many crossings at
twice a day
minimum there is for those trucks so
that area along with the timber company
which in my
i'm understood that is growing plus all
the other businesses that are down that
rights road
then on top of that air um park and ride
will just
it the environment is just massively
different double days road
no question i used to live down there
when i was a child and woodford glenn
was down there
then but now it's a very different beast
to what it what
what it was then and you can still see
tailbacks on big nights
um and during the day trying to get into
woodford glen so
you're not going to be moving 60 k's
anyway in fact most of the time you're
lucky if you're moving 10
so you know all of those things put into
this particular piece of road
i think it's absolutely important that
we support this
and that this happens i i don't think
this sets precedent for our other roads
i think that if we take the individual
roads
like this and look at them individually
i think we'll make sensible decisions
around what it is
we need to do thank you i'll put that
all those in favor please say aye
contrary to clear that
carriage now to item 11 which is the
health and safety report mr palmer pages
87 to 98
thank you mr mayor monthly report
uh no major issues to identify
progress with refurbishment of the
rangiora service center is progressing
well
and pretty much in accordance with the
timetable that
was developed
other than that i'm happy to take any
questions that people may have
any questions we have a recommendation
with recounts reckons seconded by
council of duty
would you like to speak counseling
council duty
any other speakers no right to reply
i'll put that all those in favor please
say aye contrary to clear that carried
we have a series of committee minutes
for information
so i'm here to move the recommendation
12.1 to
12.5 be received against the balance
council duty discussion
laser favorite country carried
come to item 13 which is the community
board minutes for information
the recommendation there is 13.1 to 13.5
be received for information
someone prepared to move that council
meeting secretary councillor redmond
just on those particular community board
minutes is there anything any
board members in those areas would like
or councillors
and those broad areas like to highlight
the discussion put that all those in
favor please say i
can't try to clear that carriage
no reports for information no
correspondence
next is my diary 16.1
pages 188-192
any questions it's a recommendation
i'm prepared to move councillor williams
signature by
councillor atkinson i wish to speak
any further speakers i'll put the
recommendation all those in favor please
say i
contrary to clear that kerry
okay um portfolio updates the first is
evie relationships we haven't had a
meeting of maitahi
yet this year it's coming up soon um
but i have had uh discussions with both
uh tanya
who's the new chair of the rooney uh
i've got a meeting coming up with
uh jay who's the um going to be the new
general manager he's been officially
welcomed
onto the line he's in in his role and um
all accounts a really impressive guy
actually was
um i think he had a high ranking role
uh with get worker airport i understand
and some other uh corporate experience
so he's going to bring a
a real um well he's got the potential to
make a real difference
down there with our and i'm very excited
about
um that potential uh with him and also
for both tanya
i've also had a meeting with tamari
separately um very pleased that he'll be
um
relieving their workload considerably
he's to become the third representative
from winner on our
mahitahi committee which is also good
as i mentioned earlier i had caught up
with some of the aunties at the tktt
10th anniversary and are very pleased
with
our inclusion and our draft long-term
plan for the footpath in fact
the words by dejan expressed to me was
that denise came back and she still
doesn't stop smiling so
um that's really great but um
it's making that difference in terms of
our relationship here um
we're moving the annual huey date um it
was
there was some dates being suggested but
cyril will be in touch with that but
it's the time
with um jamaica's appointment and to be
after that it
was scheduled to be about the 21st i
think
of march there's no point in looking at
that around that date
when it's only about a week or so later
that um
jim will be in his role so it seemed
logical that we
shifted that date and that was an
agreement with tania
and others as well so the relationship i
think is going as well as it
can be and
feel pretty optimistic about the area
here looking forward to our
next mahitahi and obviously area in ygn
any questions
category water management strategy
sandra is not here today
so um obviously there won't be an update
um there
international relationships you know
captain america um
passenger meeting first one 29th
february soon and
not too much happening with the china at
the moment so we'll
wait till then okay um regeneration
uh council begging very much to report
the pontoon meeting and the or the river
river area meeting in the a master
meeting we were we
um the mayor and i covered off this
morning so that's done and dusted
um softball uh diamond opens on saturday
if you
you're not running away for the weekend
it's um it's in the middle of
kaiapoi's white hangi thingy but that's
okay so it's sort of
on top of another event but that's all
right um 12 15 is the opening
for that for half an hour if you're
around there in the area
on saturday um i went down into
macintosh's
hole and just had a look at the ecan
project on the stop bank
there three bigger diggers all busy
piling rocks in there so that's
proceeding
at that pace the ante well it's the
empty i'm going to say
as part of the anti-tsunami partly
anti-waimak digging a
digging the corner out project that's
going well that's all i've got to report
any questions of council blackie
thanks um next is climate change and
sustainability council meetings
sorry i actually have a little bit to
report
[Laughter]
yeah um just a few things i guess have
been happening um the regional climate
change working group
met in december to work on a detail on
that detailed regional climate
change risk assessment and now that that
has been adopted
the next step is to get tonkin and
taylor to come back in and do a detailed
risk assessment
for the region just to just to follow up
on that first pass high level
assessment they did at the end of 2019
which will take into account the
district specific issues
like for instance coastal erosion isn't
really a problem here in wymac but it is
for timaru and waimati
um you know those so it's something
that's more specific to us
their next year in group meeting will be
at the end of february to monitor the
progress of that report
the youth council are looking into
picking up work on
the an eco pledge um which had been
a project started by one of our grad
students who since moved on so
um they went to pick that up possibly as
one of their environmental
projects which is quite cool
um the council sustainability champions
met on the 25th of jan and
just we got updates on the internal
three-bin system
being implemented in our
in our buildings and the allocation of
staff time for sustainability matters
because that can be a bit of a sticking
point with some of the departments
the progress of our energy audits and
proposed changes to our internal
catering policy so
you guys would have noticed like on our
um
long-term plan thing like the catering
stuff looks a little bit different less
plastic
less you know junk um
and the let's see i'll just skip a few
bits here um progress
against the actions that are in the
organizational sustainability strategy
and action plan
will be reported to audit and risk on
the 16th of february
meeting and the proposed changes to the
internal
standard reporting template will now
have a prompt for climate impacts and
sustainability which is great that's
been circulated as a draft
on the 25th of jan and that's scheduled
to be considered by the management team
in
february i have had a look at it and i
can't find it anywhere i'm not sure
where
where i put it but um it looked good to
me but i'm quite looking
i'm i'm quite looking forward to
actually i've seen something
finally be at the bottom of our reports
that actually um
means that people need to you know think
about that
and tick that box before they send a
report out because it needs to be in
everything that we do
so bring it on
um yesterday i attended a zoo meeting
with
a lady from up in auckland on greyland's
quahog cup project about how that works
it's like a coffee cup
um
a project that looks to get rid of
takeaway cups basically and how you know
with their learnings and how we can roll
something like that out
and in the ymca duty and and what
they're doing is really quite cool
because it's a
it's really a great inclusive community
initiative with some good potential for
us to use down here
um so i'm sure you'll hear more about
that later and also
jeff meadows and mike o'connell and i
met with
enc yesterday just about our
sustainability strategy what it is how
it works
and how they can get started in their
own strategy and how they might also be
able to help our
steer our local businesses in the same
direction toward more sustainable
practices so that was a really
productive meeting
um and yeah just just as a parting
comment you know
i'm sure you've all heard you know we we
all know that you know the climate
commissions report was just released on
sunday
you know there's no surprises on the
direction of travel there
um you know it's it's good that we've
already started
work on climate change and
sustainability here in our council
and whilst you know we're off to a good
start we've got good strategy and
policies and that in place but we need
to make sure we adhere to it
you know what we decide around this
table and what we ultimately
will be held responsible for must be
implemented you know it's got to follow
through to what our business units and
our staff do on the ground or
we're all going to pay dearly for that
not just in carbon terms
but financially while we're playing
catch up and reputationally
so i think that's a risk that we all
need to consider and make sure that
those things
actually happen um and back up our words
with action so
anyway that's that's it for me thank you
thanks thank you
any questions of course you're going to
the
canterbury mural forum regional or
mayoral forum
area um discussion next week yes oh yes
that is coming up yes
indeed so that's uh all the um councils
from within the canterbury mural forum
area coming together with
representatives from each of their
they've got that sort of portfolio lead
to come together and talk about climate
change issues so
that is on a wednesday next wednesday if
there's something else to you
actually but i somehow missed it in my
report
okay thank you great thanks nikki all
right
um business promotion and town centres
council award
um well it's been christmas time
and things been a bit quiet in january
but um
just prior to christmas we did have a
meeting
with um with our lighting consultant and
he
um presented some ideas on lighting for
cowboy
and ringura which looked um really
exciting but um we'll be um taking that
to
the um to the
community boards to have a look at the
suggestions and then coming back with
some ideas
so that's work in progress of course
um i've also been involved with um the
cardboard south mixed use workshops
which of course you will
starting to get a feel of today and
we'll we'll
get to see the whole picture next week
also the refurbishment discussions um
and we're looking at on the east wing
a councillors space or councillor's room
and the idea at the moment getting some
prices to
split the safe room in half and but
pushing the wall out east to include
window window outlook and
with refreshment facilities for
councillors
um moving forward because it was um
decided that
with a large enlargement of the council
chambers that
there was really needs to be a space for
comforters to
um retreat to and to use as a meeting
room so
that's all for me thank you thanks
counselor well just on
that last point is a brief on the
briefing agenda for next week there will
be an update
from rob on that particular matter and
for your input
at that point so any questions of
counsel council duty
thank you just talking about the safe
is that he be concrete or what is it
well yes it is because i
when i actually had a lot myself the
other day um
but it is possible and the rob will give
the update next week but
all that space is no longer required so
effectively where rosie sits now there's
actually a
was a was a hole in the ball originally
um so
there's a possibility of going through
there creating a connection
taking the backing down which will then
open it up to a
window space which will also enable a
kitchenaid in there as well so
you'll see that next week and any
colleagues that want to visualize that
we can
arrange a viewing at some point because
it's
um and apparently with counseling
consumers on the panel
sort of lighting that you've got these
days will
lighten it up fairly well i was
concerned that you'd end up with that
wi-fi and that but there's boosters that
can be put in there because
it's like a bunker now but it'll be a
very safe be probably one of the safest
areas in the council to be in
but um next week that'll um you'll be
able to see that
for yourself okay
i have no questions uh
no agent general business now moved to
matters to be considered
by the public excluded i'll move the
recommendation
someone paid a second council becky any
discussion
all those in favor please say aye
contrary to clear